[Music]
all right bro sound okay chip
it's kid yeah I need you to feel it it's
cold it's gray you're covered in pelts
oh and you're auditioning with some big
Hollywood star oh really
who and action hold brothers the Beast
can smell your fear
dragon show yourself
[Music]
sorry I didn't see that in the script
was this push to UM knock me over
hey it's your bit all you need to do is
leap on this mark when I say no no no no
get back I'll just explain the Q the Q
is ah okay be honest toothless do I come
across as too broody mm because off the
tongue I'm just trying to remember where
I left my keys brothers no all of us
will see daybreak
but dragon show yourself
toothless no no put it down it's down
lunch everybody
kaitlin's top-notch mate I got you
salmon I'm a little confused about my
part really
I mean first I'm dead then I'm not no
one knows you my mother is brothers we
have four strong we have fought hard and
we must continue to fight until our foes
are defeated
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
toothless would you mind if I am can we
get him cleaned out please
this is Belk son it was the home of your
grandparents and the UH grandparents
before that but out there beyond the age
of the world why is the home of the
Dragons
and I believe that your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you don't know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay how am I supposed to get down hey
buddy
wait up
[Music]
he's not the only one
[Music]
another night Furies more like a right
I'm night hearing yeah yours is better
probably there is an armada with enough
cages for all of our dragon vein
this is a new kind of enemy we need to
find the hidden world I wouldn't destroy
everything you love
you're nothing without your dragon
if criminal succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up gang we have one shot a thing
you brought a baby to a battle I
couldn't find a sitter
the hidden worlds have really touched
the key
right but inside
well what Kunis not a word
[Music]
[Music]